SPEAKER: The first
key to monitoring
GKE cost optimization
is ensuring
that cluster administrators
have an understanding of how
much of their cluster resources
are actually used by workloads
in the cluster.
With this data,
they can take steps
to ensure that fewer cluster
resources are idle or wasted.
Let's take a look at how
we can utilize a monitoring
system around this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As we explored in
the previous video,
the concept of bin
packing is focused
on ensuring that most
of our cluster resources
are allocated to
cluster workloads.
Cluster administrators
want to achieve
efficient bin packing to
ensure that a cluster is not
overprovisioned.
Monitoring systems will be able
to tell cluster admins if this
is the case by letting them
know how much of a cluster's
allocatable resources
are actually
consumed by workload requests.
There are three
main areas we want
to monitor to ensure that we
are not straining resources
across our cluster.
CPU, memory, and the amount
of pods we run on each node.
CPU and memory are well-known
concepts in Kubernetes,
so let's start
with how we should
monitor how well
they're actually
allocated in a cluster.
Up to this point, we
have discussed monitoring
at the aggregate cluster level.
With per-cluster
monitoring, we are
getting a high-level
summary of how well we are
doing with cluster bin packing.
However, the larger the
cluster and the more diverse
the machine types,
the more important
it becomes to monitor
at a more granular level
that will help cluster
administrators take action.
Monitoring at the more
granular per-node pool level
can help us take this action.
This monitoring can help
identify target areas
that cluster administrators can
improve cluster bin packing.
For example, if we are
isolating a set of workloads
to their own node pool
that is not correctly
sized to fit such
workloads, underutilization
may not appear to be a problem
at the aggregate cluster level,
but it could very well be a
problem within that node pool.
For both cluster level and
node pool-level monitoring,
we should collect these four
metrics around CPU and memory.
Allocatable resources,
which references
total CPU or memory available
from the cluster or node pool.
This value will always
be slightly lesser
than the total resources
from the cluster
VM due to critical
system components that
have to run on each node.
Requested resources, which
references total CPU or memory
requested by pods running
in the cluster or node pool.
Recommended resources, which
reference recommended CPU
or memory requests from
the platform, which
can come from components such
as vertical pod autoscaler.
And finally, used resources,
which references the actual CPU
or memory utilization from
pods in a cluster or node pool.
In this example dashboard
for monitoring CPU,
we can see how these four
metrics fall together
over a specified time window.
This graph tells
us, for instance,
that there is opportunity
for cost optimization
due to used cores falling well
below the requested core count
by workloads in the cluster.
However, when looking at
this example dashboard
for monitoring memory, we
get a much better picture
of what is going on.
Workloads are requesting
and using most of the memory
we have available, but barely
utilizing the CPU available.
With this information,
we can consider
the types of machines we
are running in our cluster
or in our node pool.
Can we provision VMs with
the same amount of memory
but with less CPU?
With the appropriate
data at hand,
we can now begin this exercise
of answering this question
to practice cost optimization.
The third area we should monitor
to ensure efficient bin packing
is pods per node.
In GKE, users can set the
number of pods allowed
to run on a node to
smaller than the default
value, which is 110 pods.
This is commonly
used as a mechanism
for preserving IP addresses,
since each pod in a cluster
or in a node pool
gets its own IP.
This feature in GKE is
called flexible pod CIDR.
If you set a small enough
number of pods on a node,
there's a chance that you
could schedule the maximum pods
per node without using a
majority of the allocatable CPU
and memory on that node.
This is also possible even
with the default value
of 110 pods per node, should
you have very large nodes
with smaller workload requests.
Thus, it's important to
monitor when you brush up
against the maximum
pods on a given node,
especially if you're attempting
to achieve IP address
preservation.
Monitoring across
these key areas
will help cluster
admins continually
optimize their
cluster infrastructure
in a data-driven fashion.
This is especially important
as workloads scale up and down
and when new tenants
onboard into the cluster.
Be sure to check out
the paper we published
on how to set up this
monitoring system, linked
in the description below.
Setting this monitoring
up will lay the groundwork
for the cluster admins to
work with cluster tenants
to ensure that they
are doing the work
to perform at right sizing.
We'll cover this in the
next video, so stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]